CBS News contributor Bob Schieffer spoke
last night with Republican Senator John
McCain the conversation took place at
the International Republican Institute
s-- Freedom dinner while Schieffer asked
John McCain about the Comey memo and
questions surrounding the Trump
administration the only thing I can say
is I think we've seen this movie before
I think it's reaching the point where
it's of Watergate size and scale and a
couple of other scandals that you and I
have seen it's a centipede that the shoe
continues to drop what would you advise
President Trump to do about this same
thing that you and others advised
Richard Nixon what you didn't do and
others that have been involved in
something this nature get it all out
it's not going to be over until every
aspect of it is thoroughly examined and
the American people have made a judgment
and the longer you delay the longer it's
going to last Bob Schieffer joins us now
from Washington Bob good morning to you
you know there seems to be a lot of
dropping shoes these days what was your
reaction when you heard John McCain use
the word Watergate and now we're hearing
impeachment - well John McCain is what
they call a straight shooter this is not
the first time I've gotten a straight
answer for him John McCain I go back a
long ways in fact I interviewed his
father in Vietnam in 1966 before I even
knew him John McCain is deeply worried
about this I think he believes that
Donald Trump is in serious trouble right
now and it is up to Donald Trump to get
himself out of it he met that and
repeated it he has to get all the facts
out on the table he has to find some way
to reassure people of the weather this
what this is all about and as I talked
to many Republicans last night their
feeling is growing that until they get
this settled not much else is going to
happen there's with the Trump
administration there's also this feeling
that what might be the straw that breaks
the camel's back and that it has to be
someone or a group of people boom within
the Republican
Ardi within the Congress who go to the
president and say these are the
circumstances unless something happens
here you're going to be an even deeper
trouble than you ever imagined
I don't think Charlie worked at that
point yet but I think the next thing
that has to happen
I think Comey will come before is one of
the committees on Capitol Hill and he
will give his version of this whole memo
thing once that happens then we all know
where this goes after that I talked to
one Republican this was a heavily
Republican audience last night I talked
to one Republican who said look he can
either go the way of Richard Nixon or he
can go the way of Ronald Reagan he has
got to get this all out on the table
once and for all and until he does that
we really don't know what's going to
happen but this thing has been raised to
not ch-charlie this is this is escalated
beyond where it was last week one of the
other details that we're learning from
the New York Times as excellent
reporting is that right before the
president allegedly told his FBI
director to let it go on the flint
investigation he told his attorney
general jeff Sessions and his vice
president Mike Pence to leave the room
yes and and McCain
I asked McCain about this last night and
one of the things he said was he is
dealing Trump President Trump is dealing
with a very smart lawyer right now I
mean apparently he made these memos and
told others about it so there will be
others who will be able to testify if
that becomes necessary what happened
when when this meeting was taking place
this is this is becoming very very
serious Senator McCain said last night
he does not yet think it is to the point
of obstruction of justice but so much
now depends on what former director
Comey tells Congress he's almost certain
to come there and testify before the
committee go ahead and die I thought one
of the most interesting things two of
your conversation last night McCain has
distrusted Russia for many
but his what he said about President
Trump inviting the Russian Foreign
Minister and ambassador into the Oval
Office was tough it was unbelievable I
mean he said and let me just read here
he said being friendly with a guy who's
boss Vladimir Putin sent aircraft with
precision weapons to attack hospitals
and Aleppo it is unacceptable I would
never ever invite him into the Oval
Office a KGB stooge him yes when he said
that the room erupted in very heavy
applause I take that to mean that
Republicans are becoming worried about
where this goes from here and what else
is interesting is if the President had
been taping all his conversations will
somebody get hold of those tapes and
what impact will that have well I think
they'll certainly try to subpoena them
somebody will if in fact there are such
tapes and this will be another of those
details that we'll find out in the
coming week but I just want to emphasize
again this has moved up a notch to where
it was last week when it was about you
know White House aides running around
trying to get their story straight this
is really concerning Republicans Mitch
McConnell said yesterday we could do
with less drama and what he was saying
was look until we get this settled we're
going to have a hard time moving this
agenda Bob thank you so much thank you